hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the midnight shift oh
well we're right into that now in the
previews for this game and all the
screenshots that I saw there's a
gratuitous amount of mannequins in fact
the normal war hey I was inside the
snack machine I'm sorry about that
okay so if you know me you know that I
don't like mannequins and a gratuitous
amount of mannequins just so happens to
be anything more than zero bro we've got
damn I don't like that I don't like that
at all can you guys see anything in the
flashes of light from the Lightning cuz
I can on this side up okay we're
surrounded by big box berries there's
tiny box simisage oh hey this a
mannequin it's gonna wander right by
that and hope nothing bad happens to me
okay alright I am going to die so
awfully disturbing on this poster is
explicitly dark applier okay sleepiness
is a safety hazard whatever you see I
suppose that's a subtle way of telling
me not to sleep on the job oh boy legs
my favorite pastime alright what am I
supposed to do with legs alright there's
something glowing over here I can only
assume that I should stare casually at
it roughly doubling my tumbly let me
take the key okay
well got that I'm sure nothing changed
no mannequins did done reassemble around
me
hey leg are you doing all right sure are
a lot of legs here oh hi how are you
doing great me too oh hi how are you
doing great
me too hi are you missing a leg there
me too oh nice
hi why did any oh hi oh hi hi hi hi okay
I don't like this place huh
no kiddin oh I didn't know that my
memoirs were here it's true in about the
place okay if any of you sacks of [ __ ]
decide to move and stand behind me I'm
gonna be incredibly pissed off not
enough to do anything but enough to lash
out like a cornered animal i bare my
teeth and kind of like scratch at you or
something like that oh hi oh is that is
that a present for me well you shouldn't
have you really really shouldn't okay
well this is a bad sign if ever I saw
one
oh right oh hi my favorite TV show all
right yeah it's me around storage room
eh
yeah all right well good I'm glad we
start a lot of mannequin parts those are
gonna be awfully helpful please clean up
after yourself about now I just pissed
my pants i shat on the floor in the
corner you expect me to clean that up no
got a job to do when it ain't that also
wire my eyeballs a bad VHS tape okay all
right exit is locked I'm going back I
don't know how to deal with the problem
as conundrum is that all right who's
around the corner eeny meeny miny moe
catch a tiger by the toe if you are a
mannequin go [ __ ] yourself
Oh nice ass all right hello how are you
you good oh all right well at least they
don't seem to be autonomous which is
like a girl who's like a good thing yeah
once they start charging after me that's
when I start running really fast Lee Oh
dad ass okay not so bad you just dropped
a bunch of heads on me I've dealt with
worse I'm still coming for that booty
swiggity swooty all right
swiggity swooty I'm going away from the
bowl well that's not good ah you stop
that right now
you lose hi hello friend how are you why
are they okay ah praise the Sun I'll
just be on my way oh hi whoo nice okay
all right then I don't like you I don't
like you at least you're not staring at
me okay here I go
I hate this yeah yeah what does that is
an exit key great I'll take that
good what happened I don't like it I'll
put it back I'll put it back I swear
okay all right
we're fine hey how's it going friendly
hug no I mm-hmm hi nice ass all right
hello how are you just minding my own
business I hate everything about this
okay all right if you could stop
rumbling praise the Sun hey hi don't
mind me
it's gonna me and her my way out excuse
my spit hey hey hi Oh No
you've had an unfortunate leg accident
oh all right you know I wasn't thinking
of going back anyway so you guys can
just you know have fun by yourself on
your own in this hellhole hi hi I just
hate them
well that did nothing I took two tries
okay got it though I got it oh this
looks whoa-ho hi how are you doing okay
well I will pretend like that didn't
happen we know about your problem is it
mannequins or is it all the poop in my
pants I can't decide which problem I'm
more concerned about the juncture okay
all right
was that use at me getting a little bit
of compression up in here
hi oh you seem to have a problem - I
don't like you okay all right yeah this
goats why what all right guess I'm free
what the hell play the credit say yes
okay why did this why did this game need
an executive producer huh check out my
other works I don't think I want to all
right Edmonton digital arts college oh I
had a flashlight well Ida oh why would I
ever have wanted to turn that off that's
my initial question there also what does
this note say storage key is missing God
now out gummy Nick is so tense now that
I'm out of that game I can see how silly
that was thank God I'm such a [ __ ] baby
I'm such a [ __ ] baby
I don't like mannequins I never have I
don't know what it is about him I hate
mannequins like this isn't like this is
a decent game it's obviously got some
thought put into it it's not super
polished but god damn I ain't mannequins
I don't even know what it is I don't
know what it is about mannequins such as
a mannequin I can't stand this has been
midnight shift uh it needs some work
there's a lot of things that need to be
put into it before it's a real game but
not too bad plays into my phobia pretty
well so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down the comments below then as always
[Music]